and it's just a few days that Game of
Thrones premiere I was just thinking
it's been nearly two years since the
last season it's not crazy I feel that
just yesterday I remember that show like
the back of my hand
oh that one guy was like I didn't think
was gonna die and then he died yeah the
weddings there was eggs right there's
things it was the hey be honest what I
don't remember what happened in the
shadow never anything a saml and I I
want to catch up but I don't know what
do we do you just start from the
beginning
wait refresh your memory it was seven
seasons no commercials that's true that
a 67 hours that's easy
I've got that kind of time Ryan stood
[Music]
was that high winter tyrion the only
thought you keeping track of the
lannisters how does it season one this
is so much Baxter I don't even
understand what's going on we should
just treat it like a bug a test right
like we're in school cramp pop quiz
where is the iron bank Winterfell are
you asking me are you telling me
seriously I need someone to tell me I
don't know what would help is if they
come up with like a rhyme that help us
remember what each character does like
Cersei yes yes like Cersei shows no
mercy
Melisandre Mets song
Dondre I don't know what was that never
left area right what if we did a shot
every time someone got naked super smart
oh I don't remember their bigness with
nudity now I need a nap Paul we got 43
more episodes left all right you know
what we need a little pick-me-up okay
check it out man I've never done a drug
in my life I can't do coke come on man
did you care about the season 8 premiere
of killed Thrones everyone's gonna be
talking about it there you go winter is
gone man
I don't know grandma maybe this time I
just have to figure out how to find your
own insulin huh whoa what's going on
with you my wife just secta my kids says
40 oh my god purple wedding my favorite
opus of communica told you this is gonna
be fun I think I have to do is trust me
here have a drink
[Music]
why did you say this is your favorite
episode oh yeah acting with this yeah
it's like break grandfather's chair why
maybe I want to sit in it you can't I
will you won't you it's my birthright
it's like claim wait a second wait wait
wait what are we doing what are we doing
we leave a few hours to go we can do
this where did I go there oh sorry
you know it let's do this together
[Music]
we did it we did we did I get Wow 67
hours actually went by really way dude
actually Wow we still got a couple hours
to spare you thinking what I'm thinking
big little I all right Benjen
[Music]
you